[Applause]
all right now it is time for Borderlands
3 you guys ready all right please
welcome for gearbox Paul sage I'm built
pretty well you've been traveling around
the world there's much borderland stuff
going on but we don't wait much longer
for this coming in September September
13th so let's talk Borderlands 3 first
of all the campaign and last week a lot
of previews went up influencers press
got to play it so we got a little
footage of campaign we're gonna talk
about first before we get to talking
about the endgame which we're very
excited about but tell us a bit about
the campaign and sort of what you guys
have shared recently on Borderlands 3
all right so we showed off about four
hours of just the beginning gameplay
where you start on Pandora and then we
moved on to Eden six which is a new
planet we've never showed out before and
we tell this kind of heartwarming story
of two ai's who fall out of love and one
AI who's a jilted lover takes and shoves
the other AI just straight up into a
pink plush bear who is voiced by none
other than the CRA's Matic ice-t there
you go ice-t alright in Portal a story
of course right now you've got obviously
amazing characters playable flack I mean
people are super excited about what
you've shown kind of on campaign and the
thing though that everyone want is
always curious now I know it's kind of
silly to be talking about the end game
before the game season out but folks
want to know you know what's the
challenge what are you know what what
can you tell us about the end game for
Borderlands three alright so all this
week and probably next week in a few
more weeks we're gonna be talking about
endgame yeah first two things we're
gonna talk about the first one is called
a circle of slaughter bring no excessive
slaughter from Borderlands yep right and
it's just this wave after wave survival
mechanic of fighting off enemies and the
cool thing about this is that you know
the more you survive the better your
rewards are and there's more though
right there is more so we're announcing
something called proving grounds okay
okay proving grounds starts off with the
yridians right
chair right we're showing off you know a
little bit of the proving grounds here
and the nice thing is you have to go
throughout the game and discover yridian
writing this is this ancient alien race
and then you find the coordinates to
Planet so once you kind of decipher all
these things and then you find out that
you can take a mission from this iridium
that you see here and the mission has
different objectives in it right so it's
got one which is kill everything because
Borderlands and then it's got optional
objectives like don't die all right do
it within a certain amount of time kill
a certain thing so you can see all that
yeah yeah you can see the optional
objectives right here and then the nice
thing about the optional objectives is
that if you do those optional objectives
at the end we have a chest and the loot
gets better the how the optional
objectives play out so if you're really
good you'll get the best loot in the
game super replayable obviously people
look out it's all about replayability at
this point yeah awesome well that's
amazing it's so time-based obviously
going through there with you and my
friends and having an amazing time so
this obviously the proving grounds this
is one map are there multiple proving
grounds obviously yeah there's about
seven different proving grounds
scattered throughout the grave I'm
actually sorry I said in seven minutes
six but you know it works I'm sure
they'll be more down the road right
that's all right so that's and there's
I'm sure there's probably even more
in-game or there's all sorts of in-game
you know again like I said we're gonna
talk about it more we have something
called Guardian rank which is if you
play Borderlands 2 it's like badass rank
2.0 we talking a lot about that so yeah
a lot of stuff coming up all right well
we don't have to wait long for
Borderlands 3 but it's so awesome to see
proving grounds and when can we check it
out well you will be able to check it
out on Friday the 13th that's September
13 2009 teen I hope everybody is there
oh yeah and I'm sure you're gonna have
it playable here at Gamescom so ever
it'll be chubs now right all right
borderlands 3 the guys from gearbox ball
thing
you get off games come with us really
appreciate it alright so now we've got a
cool new game to show you guys and this
come